you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
with only two weeks to go before the
global climate summit america's
ambitions are under threat from one of
the president's democratic colleagues
a ford factory merseyside is to become
the company's first site in europe
making parts for electric cars
and why the government's advisors say
carbon capture is key to the uk reaching
net zero by 2050.
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now we're just two weeks away from the
start of cop 26 the global climate
summit that many say is the last chance
for leaders to commit to action that
will stop the climate crisis
but ambitious steps the u.s president
wants to take to tackle climate change
head-on are under threat from one of his
own democratic party colleagues
well while joe biden races to get his
plans past congress the way the event
has been organized is facing criticism
as our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter reports
two weeks to go until the cop 26 u.n
climate summit in glasgow
it's been described as the world's last
best hope to limit global warming but
there may be a big problem looming
when we spoke to u.s special envoy on
climate change john kerry earlier this
month he commented on the stalling
progress of a bill that contains a
sweeping plan to decarbonize america's
electricity at that point he was still
confident the sausage making is not
pretty
but in the end they're going to have a
sausage i believe
and
my hope is that it includes the critical
components of what we need to be able to
deal with the climate crisis
but that is now in doubt because of this
man senator joe manchin a democrat from
the coal reliant state of west virginia
who wields a decisive vote in the senate
he is refusing to support the clean
power plan and it may be withdrawn
suddenly the united states a global
leader in the fight against climate
change urging other nations to do more
looks like it can't follow its own
advice
with potentially huge consequences
it makes it more difficult for the us to
push china and other countries to do
more
towards net zero emission reduction
targets in mid-century if china and
those other countries can say
you've set a target but you're not
making progress towards implementing it
which they've already put out as a
defensive shield against the pressure on
them to do more
america's domestic political problems
are not the only issue the government's
cop 26 unit in westminster is having to
consider at the moment
it's emerged that some of the summit's
main corporate sponsors including sky
have previously written to the
government raising concerns about the
way it was being organized and activists
are complaining about ongoing problems
with the availability and cost of
accommodation which might prevent them
from attending
in a statement a cop 26 spokesperson
said we are committed to hosting an
inclusive summit in two weeks time which
showcases innovative work from a range
of businesses and civil society groups
who are committed to tackling climate
change together ministers are continuing
to focus their time on helping to secure
a positive outcome in glasgow
organizing an international summit is
not an easy task and at this crucial
moment as nearly 200 nations each with
individual needs and pressures prepare
to gather in glasgow delivering a
successful one will be even harder
hannah thomas peter sky news in
westminster
a ford factory in merseyside is to
switch away from making parts for petrol
vehicles to making components for
electric cars it's won government
funding from a 500 million scheme which
is part of the prime minister's green
industrial revolution helen and smith
has more
so this is clearly good news for the
people of merseyside and in particular
the 500 or so workers whose jobs are
going to be secured into the coming
years and hopefully the coming decades
as well that factory moving from making
uh gearboxes that go in internal
combustion engine cars to making these
new
electric power units components of
electric cars and a big financial
investment in that plant as well in
excess of 200 million pounds and a big
chunk of that has come from the
government it's come from the
government's automotive transformation
fund which is essentially a big pot of
money put aside not only to incentivize
these manufacturers to push their
electric lines but also to make sure
that they don't lose out in the process
because of course we know that by 2030
these manufacturers are not going to be
allowed to sell petrol diesel cars
anymore so in a sense i think that fund
is working we know it's also benefited
nissan at vox uh vauxhall as well in the
past few months but in terms of making
sure that there's more green cars more
electric cars on our roads it's not just
what happens in the factories that
matters but it's also what happens in
the streets because there needs to be
the infrastructure to support it and
there's another piece of research out
this week from an organization called
new automotive which has essentially
collated a lot of the data around this
charging network and just how good it is
just how robust it is to support the
transition that's going on and the
message from them i think is really that
they need to see a bit more urgency and
a bit more speed in terms of upping that
charging network at the moment there's
around 24 000 charging stations in this
country and they estimate that by the
middle of next decade there's going to
need to be about a quarter of a million
last year around 27 a day being
installed they say that needs to be up
to around 40 or 50 a day if we're going
to be meeting those targets so a big
overhaul is underway yes an overhaul in
manufacturing and that's important but
there needs to be a broader
infrastructure overhaul as well
in some of today's other climate news
the former u.s vice president and
environmentalist al gore says he
believes a majority of republicans are
in favor of decisive action on climate
change and that young people view the
climate crisis as a problem that must be
sold regardless of political agenda
young people are leading in my country
and in every country now so i think the
landscape is changing quite dramatically
uh and there is now a growing demand
from the grassroots activists regardless
of political party and i think that's
going to make a big difference in the
elections ahead
the first five million pound winners of
prince william's earthshot prize have
been announced a scheme in costa rica
paying local citizens to restore natural
ecosystems and coral vita a company
growing coral 50 times faster than
traditional methods were amongst the
winners the prizes will be awarded every
year for the next 10 years to earth
shots which are ambitious ideas to help
biodiversity and tackle climate change
an invasive tree species is causing
water shortages in cape town in south
africa specialist crews are removing 54
000 hectares of pine trees which are
using around 55 billion litres of water
every year south africa's timber
industry relies on these trees but the
seeds are easily dispersed from
plantations to protected nature reserves
putting local flora at risk
now the uk's ambition to achieve net
zero carbon by 2050 focuses on using
more renewable energy but the
government's climate watchdog is warning
that this target is unlikely to be
reached without greater use of carbon
capture and storage technology which is
still untested at scale our economics
editor ed conway reports
somewhere in the north sea miles off the
coast of scotland a revolution is about
to take place
oil and gas fields which once pump
fossil fuels out of the ground are now
promising to help solve climate change
it is a remarkable controversial claim
but it goes to the very heart of the
race to net zero
to see why we need to chase these
underwater pipes connecting the rigs and
oil fields back to where they meet land
this is one of the main pipelines taking
natural gas from the north sea all the
way through
into the grid so 10 to 20 of what goes
into your boiler into the electricity
system it's passing right under my hands
but that is only the start of the story
because the plan is to take carbon
dioxide from various industrial
processes pressurize it liquefy it put
it into this pipeline and send it down
under the ground
into the north sea that at least is the
idea
gas is coming from the north sea it's
been cleaned up and it's been sent into
the national grid to go to everybody's
homes around the country i think in 30
50 years time you're going to see still
that process continuing but what you'll
see is in reverse
a carbon capture and storage facility
which is then sending the co2 that is
captured from this gas
offshore to make the gas effectively
carbon zero and they will in addition
piggy piggybacking on all of that will
be a the manufacturer of hydrogen which
of course is a net zero fuel
but you're probably wondering isn't this
just another way of fossil fuel
companies carrying on extracting fossil
fuels that's a really important point to
stress
that uh yeah even at net zero we will
continue to need
industry will continue to need oil and
gas and ccs is a technology that
actually helps us reduce the emissions
from
those
industries that still require oil and
gas so how does carbon capture actually
work well there are all sorts of
industrial processes power stations
cement manufacture and so on that create
carbon dioxide at the moment most of
that carbon just gets emitted out of the
chimney the idea of carbon capture is to
take those fumes and run them through a
special unit which removes the co2 the
common can then be stored under the
ground in places like depleted oil and
gas fields as is planned in the north
sea or it can be put to use in other
industrial processes like chemicals
plants
that at least is the plan for this the
acorn project at some focus gas terminal
except as you can probably see it is
still just that a plan
which brings us to the main thing you
need to know about carbon capture
without it all those plans to get
britain's greenhouse gas emissions down
to net zero
won't work
have you got any of those scenarios that
don't rely one way or another on carbon
capture
no is the short answer we have actually
looked at this question so in december
we published um five different scenarios
for getting to net zero uh each of them
did include carbon capture to varying
degrees
we did have a a scenario without it
but interestingly it it didn't quite get
there so without carbon capture it's
impossible is it it's not impossible but
it's much much harder i think it can be
done but it does rely ultimately on the
government putting some big policies in
place some of them quite expensive
and
for me that's the bit that's missing at
the moment
then there's the second big issue it's
never been successfully implemented at
scale
travel the country and every so often
you encounter the ghosts of carbon
capture past here is one at the old
longanic coal-fired power station in
fife
there was a whole scheme it was going to
take all of the fumes out of that
chimney and get rid of all the carbon
then in 2011
it was cancelled it was too expensive
the power station is now being
dismantled
and further north in aberdeenshire peter
head gas fire power station spent
millions of pounds on a carbon capture
storage project cancelled in 2015.
so what's different this time around
the key difference at this time is the
government's
legal commitment to achieve net zero
emissions across the whole of the
country the only way you can achieve
that particularly in these hardcore paid
industries is is to do carbon capture
use and storage this is a furnace where
you're burning natural gas another
difference is that the technology has
improved actually the main innovations
behind carbon capture have been around
for decades but new startups like carbon
clean say they can do it much more
efficiently their rig the blue one here
can do the same work maybe even more as
that enormous contraption behind it
this you can call miniature version for
a fundus or a power plant okay where you
are burning natural gas and going
straight away to a carbon capture plant
so it's going through all these pipes
and it's ending up with your machine
here correct where does the captured co2
come out and it released from the top
from there
the co2 is just released into the air is
it yeah as president is releasing to the
year okay
in other words even here at the very
cutting edge we're not quite there yet
with the clock ticking down to 2050
we're still a long way from big projects
that actually capture carbon and store
it and even leaving aside the concerns
about perpetuating fossil fuel use not
everyone is convinced until we get to
the point where there is a
a case for deploying carbon capture from
a commercial viewpoint carbon capture
will not happen
in the coming weeks tatar chemicals will
open this the country's first and
biggest industrial carbon capture
facility using that co2 to make sodium
bicarbonate and sky understands the
government is poised to announce funding
for a swathe of projects potentially
including the acorn scheme in syn fergus
but as world leaders prepare for the
crunch summit in glasgow it is clear
that for this technology and the
environment
time is of the essence ed conway sky
news
well joining us now to discuss the
climate issues of the day are the author
and broadcaster zaya tong and director
of union of justice former mep and mayor
of sheffield majeed majeed so welcome to
both of you good to see you both so
let's start with that issue of carbon
capture and storage shall we and
capturing carbon dioxide emissions
before they're allowed out into the
atmosphere to contribute to global
warming is what in a sense the holy
grail of climate solutions and the head
of the committee on climate change as
you heard in that report says more
investment is crucial if the uk is going
to reach its net zero targets but are we
relying too much on unproven
technologies
well zaya what do you make of this so
the government's advisers there saying
carbon capture has to be part of the mix
if we're going to reach
net zero so do you accept that it does
have a role to play
it may have a role but i think that the
state that we're currently seeing it is
playing a minor role i want to give you
an example there are several different
types of carbon capture technologies one
is called direct air capture we recently
saw the launch of a facility in iceland
called orca now that facility was able
to suck up about the equivalent of 800
cars only per year in terms of emissions
put another way if you imagine all the
emissions that we release in a single
year it sucks about three seconds worth
so even if you had 50 000 of these
plants that would be the equivalent of
sucking up about you know 50 000 small
villages worth now on the other hand
when we look at something like project
drawdown they have listed over 80
working solutions that we have available
to us today and in some it works out too
if we actually started utilizing the
solutions that we have on hand drawing
down
1583 gigatons by mid-century so we would
be able to reach around our 1.5 goal by
2050 if we actually use the available
technologies that we have
what do you think majid i mean obviously
the the ultimate goal would really be to
stop putting emissions out into the
atmosphere anyway but we need solutions
to capture them don't we i mean let's
just take a look at what one scientist
has said here uh trees can't absorb
enough co2 to stop climate change on
their own it's someone from mit you'll
see it in a minute anyway um
no matter how many we plant that's what
they've said so majeed
shouldn't we just be doing everything we
possibly can to try to reduce the co2 in
the atmosphere and and carbon captures
one of those things that we should be
trying
of course we should be trying everything
but of course we need to kind of have a
set of priorities so like for like for
carbon capture and storage to be viable
and increase you know in carbon capture
capacity by a factor of
and by 2030 is really required to kind
of
you know meet the paris agreement goals
but of course you know this is highly
highly unlikely to be achieved as it
takes about six to ten years for carbon
capture storage projects to complete to
begin with but not only that
and there are only i think currently
about 20 or so projects in development
worldwide which really isn't quite
enough and of course yes
carbon capture is it's a good technology
it captures more than about 90
of co2 from power plants and industrial
complex and yes it kind of of course and
constantly you know it kind of reduces
the environmental impact of the energy
sector but it is ridiculously slow in
rolling out and of course the amount of
money being thrown at it and investment
in carbon capture and storage can in my
opinion really compete with investment
in renewable energy projects which my
opinion should be taking a higher
priority and just finally because
and in the ipcc in 2018 they kind of
found that 89 of global co2 emissions
actually came from fossil fuels and
fossil fuel industry so you know instead
of trying to
play both sides and what i think we
really need to do is to understand and
accept that there is really no future
impossible dependent economy so we urge
you to need to transition away from
using fossil fuels so of course as much
as like the government wants to spend a
lot of money in investing in carbon
capture that that money could be better
spent than actually renewable energy
okay
but but even if that's the priority to
move to renewables as fast as possible
there is still that period of time when
you need to rely on fossil fuels during
that transition isn't there and and
carbon capture can can play a part there
and not least around those industries
for which there aren't really solutions
yet for reducing the amount of emissions
there are
well here is something that's rather
tricky uh as madija said uh there's
about 20 projects currently in play when
you're looking at the oil and gas
industry but if you actually look at
what they're doing they're capturing a
lot of that carbon and it's being used
in a process called enhanced oil
recovery and what enhanced oil recovery
is is you're taking that carbon and
you're pumping it into oil reservoirs as
a gas in order to do what in order to
boost oil production so this for me is a
situation that is not particularly
workable okay and majid do you think
looking more broadly we're putting too
much faith in technology that's largely
unproven at this stage or not even
invented in some cases to solve the
climate crisis generally
of course like it's
the government can say they def they
definitely need it in terms of their
plans but there's so much else that we
could do we can focus a lot on transport
like would be great if our government
and if they were to halt any expansion
of airports and introduce a frequent
flyer levy that'll be a great thing even
when we kind of look at power like our
government in my opinion should also
really pull out all the stops through
finance and regulation to really double
the speed of renewable energy roll-ups
instead of you're not importing day
energy from elsewhere so it's of course
it's it's i get it for them to say that
it's a priority for them that they need
to do but in hindsight they need to be a
bit more ambitious okay let's move on to
our other topic of the day now shall we
because the royal family is making a
habit of appearing on our program from
prince william's earthshot prize to the
queen overheard criticizing global
leaders for their lack of climate action
to prince charles and his decades-long
campaign on environmental issues but
their green credentials have also been
called into question so are they good
role models for climate action or not
well zai what do you think i mean the
family
undoubtedly has a very high profile i
mean they're known around the world not
just in this country of course a lot of
their members have used that influence
pretty positively on climate haven't
they
they absolutely have used their
influence positively but i want to say i
did a little bit of fact checking and i
looked at the royal family's carbon
footprint for the year 2019 according to
statista looking at their gas
electricity and their transport this
family emitted 8282
tons of co2 now i want you to compare
that to what the average uk household
emits that's 17 tons only so you have
one family emitting over 8 000 tons
another family emitting 17 tons i just
ask you is that fair
okay and majeed what do you think i mean
just to say let's just quote chris
packham for a second uh he said this is
a very powerful family they have a very
powerful voice and they want to do
something very powerful they could do
something very powerful for the
environment i mean do you agree that
they are likely to be influential and
people will hear what they say but will
they follow what they do i mean how
relatable are they to most people do you
think
great question and in all honesty and of
course i welcome anybody with any
cultural
influence in any shape or form to
actually talk to talk about the climate
actually get people talking about it but
i can't help but feel that the monarchy
the royal family is being a bit
hypocritical like it was recently
reported that the queen had actually
lobbied the scottish government for an
exemption from environmental protection
laws which was actually there to design
to cut carbon coming and cut carbon
emissions but not only that prince
charles of course he's done lots of
amazing things but at the same time
he kind of last year flew 125 miles by
helicopter just to make a speech about
aircraft emissions so of course on one
hand it's great that they are talking
about it but like you said for their
message to really hit home they need to
lead by example and not in one case just
telling us what we should all be doing
and what other leaders should be doing
instead kind of looking inward so
basically they can lead by example
okay majimajid zyatong we're out of time
but really good to see though thanks
very much indeed
so that's everything from us for today
do join me tomorrow on the show to
discuss all the big climate issues will
be carbon footprint print footprinting
expert
mike berners-lee and judy ling wong
honorary president of the black
environment network so thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you